hi I'm Nick Jonas and this is GQ life  advice can you hit on a woman you met at  yoga absolutely corpse it's like the  perfect environment for me the woman my  girlfriend just moved across country how  do I make this relationship work any  time you think about talking to on the  phone whether it's a text call leaving a  message whatever it is do it just do it  always I want to ask my girlfriend to  marry me what's the most romantic way of  asking her that is way above my pay  grade best piece of advice you've ever  gotten it's probably from my dad  actually he said live like you're at the  bottom even at the top Facebook me just  meant to stay humble and then a good  attitude through everything it's very  meaningful  where's piece of advice you ever gotta  take this shot you won't regret it  that was the worst  you